at the Cricket restaurant in Soho London
they prepare for evening service
staff here anxiously awaiting details of
government plans to help businesses with
the skyrocketing cost of energy owner
Rick Campbell is relieved that with
everything else he has to worry about
prime minister Liz truss has ruled out
energy rationing you've got to be
realistic you know a restaurant there's
a lot of high energy things on all the
time we could do dinner by candlelight
but it's not really going to make much
difference to the pills so I don't think
we should just discourage people from
trying to rationalize in some respects
but you have to be realistic
but Russia's invasion of Ukraine and
Vladimir Putin's slow throttling of the
gas supply has changed the calculation
for other countries action is needed
right now we must use less energy in
Ireland the conversation about reducing
consumption has begun
and Germany dependent on Russia for much
of its gas is already in the early
stages of a rationing plan
the UK is less exposed than its European
counterparts but we still have to import
energy in a volatile Global Market and
that leaves us vulnerable
UK officials are still as a matter of
course preparing for a worst case
scenario this winter a combination of
very cold weather and a problem with
Supply now in that scenario the argument
goes without rationing we run the risk
of uncontrolled blackouts
it leaves some experts asking why the
government is so reluctant to ask us to
change our Behavior it makes sense
because the gas that we don't use we
don't have to pay for
um so it brings down bills and the gas
that we don't use makes us more energy
secure in the first place
but for economists the effect on
industry makes rationing a last resort
we will have a reduction in production
potentially they wouldn't be able to
produce as much and that will have
obviously a significant consequences for
for the economy and prioritizing
economic growth is at the heart of Liz
truss's promise to voters one she seems
set on keeping even as an uncertain
winter looms Hannah Thomas Peters Sky
News